political correctness I've made video
after video criticizing political
correctness when it is overbearing often
related to feminism Islam black lives
matter transgender issues
microaggressions cultural appropriation
you name it short videos long videos
I've made videos where I've been
critical of politically correct culture
on college campuses where I denounce
trigger warnings safe spaces language
policing I've made multiple videos
debunking things Reza Aslan has said not
disconnected from political correctness
one of them is 25 minutes long I have a
long track record of going after
liberals and conservatives when they're
being unreasonable fanatical are trying
to call people bigots who don't deserve
it I've been outspoken about not being
in favor of political correctness when
it's at odds with empirical realities or
when it tries to limit free speech or
open debate but political correctness is
a complicated issue and there are
serious misconceptions about political
correctness and the term much like
regressive left is often used by
conservatives to criticize realities
that they simply do not like I'm going
to discuss with you what political
correctness really means and more
importantly how we can make productive
distinctions between overbearing
political correctness and mere social
norms that encourage us to treat each
other with respect and common decency
the first uses of the term political
correctness in the u.s. were by
right-wing ideologues in the latter part
of the 20th century merely to criticize
the left the concept of political
correctness was originally just a ruse
by conservatives to belittle progressive
attitudes and policies they said oh
you're just being politically correct if
you support things like environmentalism
gun control social safety nets or if
you're anti-war or anti-death-penalty it
was a trick at first a way of saying
that the mainstream media is liberal and
conservatives or victims and
progressives are just trying to control
the conversation and the term political
correctness
is still used in that way today outlets
like Fox News over use the term to try
to fool their conservative audiences
into believing that the left is out to
get them that by opposing progressive
ideas rather than phrases or vocabulary
they will be fighting the good fight and
doing a great deed before we pick apart
this perverted and subjugated miss
framing of political correctness I have
to point out the irony that
conservatives are just as guilty of
promoting political correctness when it
suits them including language policing
and so-called
offensive speech the war on Christmas
where Christian conservatives get
triggered if someone says Happy Holidays
or Show's deference to the undeniable
reality that not everybody's Christian
and not everybody celebrates Christmas
or when conservatives respond to
critiques of our foreign policy or
economic system by saying oh that's
anti-capitalist or anti-american or hey
you don't support the troops this is the
right-wing equivalent of shutting down
debate by saying that's offensive
something conservatives slam
progressives for doing where people
start getting confused about political
correctness is when political
correctness is conflated with simple
decency the idea of calling a
transgender person him or her based on
what they prefer to be called that's not
political correctness that's called not
being a prick if you meet someone named
Timothy and they tell you hey just call
me Tim and then you proceeded to call
them Timothy you're now a jackass how is
it going to hurt you or hurt society if
you just address people how they want to
be addressed or treat them how they want
to be treated if what they're asking is
reasonable and imposes no undue burden
upon you your rights aren't curtailed
nor your freedom of speech restricted if
you call someone a little person instead
of a [ __ ] simply because that's what
they want to be called it doesn't change
any conversation it doesn't oppress you
these are just matters of treating
someone with dignity not a matter of
manipulating discs
and controversies in an oppressive or
overbearing way it's no skin off your
back and it doesn't change the
discussion if you call someone Inuit
rather than Eskimo if you call someone a
Native American
instead of Indian if you call someone
transgender instead of [ __ ] do you
think it's a bad thing that we no longer
say colored people or use the n-word and
now we say black people or African
Americans if that's who we're talking
about no reasonable person would say
it's a terrible thing that we don't go
around calling people Negroes anymore
the fact that we don't use that word
anymore isn't because the left is trying
to control society and manipulate
people's thinking it's because black
people don't want to be called Negros
and both that term and the n-word are
linked to a horrifying and undeniable
reality of our country's past called
slavery but there were absolutely people
decades ago complaining that America had
gotten too politically correct when this
word started going away
and those people are analogous to those
today who say I'm not going to call a
transgender person him or her based on
their preference because it doesn't sit
right with me and I don't want to change
who really cares just treat people with
respect right now we're in a societal
phase where the transgender community is
gaining acceptance for the first time in
many ways calling people by their
preferred pronouns doesn't stifle your
speech allowing people to define
themselves doesn't shut down political
discussions the result is a society that
is more inviting to everyone no matter
who they are and we can see these
changes from generation to generation
people have become more tolerant and
pluralistic less bigoted over time
because of so-called political
correctness it requires the most modest
of efforts to give a damn about other
people doing otherwise usually just
presents your mere lack of understanding
of what it's like to be someone else
many people simply cannot imagine what
it would be like to be black or gay or
female whatever anti PC people often
advocate for
social justice for their own group but
not for others people who spend all of
their time talking about political
correctness also often get confused
about the idea of free speech many of
them invoke the First Amendment in
situations where it just doesn't apply
the First Amendment protects Americans
against censorship by the government any
private citizen asking you to speak a
certain way doesn't violate your First
Amendment rights but even if you use a
broader definition of censorship or free
speech like when it comes to censorship
by non government institutions
corporations colleges other
administrative bodies that sort of
censorship can sometimes be overbearing
too but there is a difference between
censorship and political correctness the
consequences of violating censorship are
institutional and official the
consequences of violating political
correctness are social if you say that's
so gay or that guy's an idiot what a
[ __ ] people may judge you and give you
a funny look but that's not censorship
that's a social expectation about
civility and empathy freedom of speech
does not mean freedom from the
consequences of that speech and there
are gray areas I mean we can have a
conversation about the Z and Z pronouns
and Canadian laws regarding speech and
transgender issues for example I see the
controversy there I get it and we can
have a debate about that there are some
institutional Civic implications with
regard to free speech compelled speech
etc when it comes to the government
telling people what to say and what not
to say
that's probably for another video but I
understand why people have a problem
with that and I wouldn't call someone
bigoted for wanting to explore those
issues but too much so-called political
correctness that isn't by institutions
and is just between individuals arises
organically and has been a natural part
of our social history just out of simple
courtesy to others and their feelings
we've stopped using demeaning terms
to refer to minorities women and
mentally disabled people I have to
question your basic capability to
empathize with other human beings if you
say those changes are censorship and are
inhibiting your ability to speak freely
it isn't thought policing we're talking
about natural changes of lexicon and
speaking habits here's the fundamental
question to explore with those who are
endlessly up in arms about the so called
disastrous impact of political
correctness what is it that you truly
want to say that you're not able to say
because of political correctness there
are still ways of speaking and not
speaking that are just inherently
growing out of our improving tolerance
towards groups that have been
marginalized historically I also don't
understand why there are people who call
themselves liberal and spend 99% of
their time complaining about political
correctness on reddit around their
YouTube channels wherever even if their
complaints about political correctness
are sometimes justified its low-hanging
fruit
yeah political correctness is sometimes
a problem and it's sometimes used to
warp debates or stop them altogether but
in and of itself it is not the Paramount
issue that some make it out to be and
quote solving political correctness
whatever that even means is not going to
improve the lives of Americans and
citizens of the world in the way that
dealing with so many other issues would
whether your audience is left-wing
right-wing or somewhere in the middle
criticizing political correctness is
just trendy right now especially on the
internet it's profitable it appeals to
people's emotions there are an endless
number of people that are hungry for
anti PC talk and it's way too easy there
are so many YouTube channels where if
you were to turn it into a drinking game
take a shot every time you hear the word
trigger warning safeSpace or regressive
while we're at it you'd be dead pretty
soon okay so talk about political
correctness and how it's bad and how
it's impacting society but then move on
to the countless
other important issues that are
impacting the world if all you talk
about is political correctness I start
to wonder whether that's the only thing
you're capable of discussing whether you
actually know enough about policy and
government to talk about other crucial
issues blogs and YouTube channels who
just moan non-stop about feminism and
trigger warnings commentators like these
are just providing intellectual fastfood
we also have to discuss the smokescreen
of hiding behind the title of classical
liberal and no I'm not calling out my
friend Dave Rubin here some so-called
classical liberals have this attitude of
I'm the real original liberal they
bastardized the term classical liberal
and use it as an excuse to rant
endlessly about political correctness
and identity politics without seriously
dealing with other issues I also suspect
that many of these people are just
closeted right-wing libertarians and
conservatives who want to hang on to
their liberal membership card and they
want to mask their social conservatism
behind a word that sounds good like
classical liberal classical liberalism
means free-market capitalism free trade
individual liberty and the ideas of John
Locke Adam Smith Thomas Jefferson
classical liberalism doesn't directly
translate to a feminism is dumb and I'll
call transgender women he domineering
political correctness and identity
politics are problems I've talked about
them no doubt but we have to understand
what domineering political correctness
is PC culture creates a problem when it
prevents us from having honest
conversations about Islam and terrorism
for example when someone writes an
article saying that all Islamic
terrorism is exclusively motivated by
politics and it has nothing to do with
religion in any way they're misled or
they're being dishonest and they are
creating an atmosphere where people are
afraid to talk about the realities of
things like martyrdom and religious
dogma
that slows down human
political correctness becomes
counterproductive when black lives
matter activists say all police officers
are racist or they take a Bernie Sanders
rally hostage just another example or
two however letting people use whatever
bathroom they want does not limit your
individual liberty calling a person in a
wheelchair disabled instead of a [ __ ]
does not repress intellectual freedom
just like refraining from using ethnic
slurs doesn't either claiming that
you're a victim of the PC police doesn't
exonerate you from being an ignoramus
proudly calling yourself politically
incorrect only rebrands your intolerance
if you're needlessly disrespecting
people and referring to everything as
political correctness makes the term
lose its meaning like so many other
terms already have so that it doesn't
have any power whenever its use is truly
warranted and even more importantly
ridicule and demean people who abuse
power corrupt politicians people who
deserve it not people who are just less
fortunate or in a marginalized group